COCKPIT.
>> SOURCES TELL CNN THAT FARIQ
AB HAMID'S PHONE WAS ON.
INFORMATION CNN HAS LEARNED THAT
MALAYSIAN AUTHORITIES GAVE TO
THE U.S. A WHILE AGO.
>> IT WOULD BE VERY RARE, IN MY
OPINION, TO HAVE SOMEONE WITH A
CELL PHONE ON IN THE COCKPIT.
IT'S NEVER SUPPOSED TO BE ON AT
ALL.
IT'S PART OF EVERY CHECK LIST
THAT I'M FAMILIAR WITH.
>> Reporter: SOURCES SAY THAT
MALAYSIAN AUTHORITIES TOLD THE
U.S. THAT A CELL TOWER IN
PENANG, MALAYSIA, ROUGHLY 200
MILES FROM WHERE THE PLANE
TURNED AROUND, PICKED UP A PING
FROM FARIQ'S CELL PHONE.
HE COULD HAVE TRIED TO DO
SOMETHING WITH THE PHONE.
WE DON'T KNOW.
>> THE INTERESTING THING ABOUT
THAT IS NO OTHER PHONE WAS
CONNECTED TO IT.
IT'S JUST SPECIFICALLY HIS CELL
PHONE.
>> THERE'S NO EVIDENCE THAT THE
FIRST OFFICER TRIED TO MAKE A
CALL WITH A PHONE.
ON SUNDAY, MALAYSIA'S TRANSPORT
MINISTER DID NOT DENY THE
POSSIBILITY.
>> AS FAR AS I KNOW, LIKE I
SAID, THAT WOULD BE IN THE REALM
OF THE SPLITS AND WHEN THE TIME
COMES, THAT WOULD BE REVEALED.
I DON'T WANT TO SPECULATE AT THE
MOMENT.
>> Reporter: WHEN THE PLANE
FIRST WENT MISSING, AUTHORITIES
SAID MILLIONS OF CELL PHONE
RECORDS WERE SEARCHED, LOOKING
FOR EVIDENCE THAT CALLS HAD BEEN
MADE FROM THE PLANE, BUT TURNED
UP NOTHING.
STILL, IT ONLY ADDS TO THE
EVIDENCE THAT THE PLANE TURNED
WESTWARD FROM ITS PLANNED PADDLE
AND THAT THE PLANE WAS LIKELY
FALLING LOW ENOUGH FOR A CELL
TOWER TO PICK UP THE SIGNAL.
>> IT DOES MAKE THEY THINK THAT
IT WAS PERHAPS LOWER THAN THE
35,000 FEET SPECULATED BECAUSE
IT DID MAKE A CONNECTION.
TYPICALLY THERE'S NOT EVEN TIME
TO DO THAT.
BU